zur deutlichen irritationen geführt hat
und auch zu einem angedrohten cdu
parteiausschuss
so ist es die rede ist von max otte der
vorsitzende der wertung union und cdu
mitglied er will kandidieren oder soll
kandidieren für die afg zur wahl des
bundespräsidenten am 13 februar darauf
gehen wir gleich ein denn wir warten
hier um 13 uhr 14 uhr 45 auf die
pressekonferenz wo er dieses dann auch
offiziell bestätigen wird die reaktion
dazu all das werden sie hier bei uns
sehen doch zunächst wollen wir uns mit
den ganz wichtigen themen dieser woche
beschäftigen da geht es natürlich um die
impf debatte morgen zunächst eine
orientierungs debatte sind schon
verschiedene gruppen anträge die
vorliegen und diese orientierungs
debatte wird vorweg geschickt am ende
soll dann irgendwann ein gesetz
rauskommen würden wie das dann aussehen
soll darüber muss dann eben in den
nächsten tagen und wochen gestritten
werden und natürlich spielt die hier
heute auch in den fraktionen die hre
eine rolle die ergebnisse gestern von
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gemeinsam mit dem bundeskanzler und
britta haßelmann die vorsitzende der
grünen-fraktion
sie hat genau das zum thema ihre
statements gemacht
in dieser woche beschäftigt uns in
politisch natürlich die lage zur nikon
die gestern stattgefundenen beratungen
der ministerpräsidenten
konferenz und die frage was folgt daraus
an
konkreten umsetzungen hier wird im
hinblick auf die frage der test
verordnung ja noch mal nachgelegt ich
glaube allen wird mit blick auf die
erschreckend hohe zahl an neuinfektionen
klar dass wir jetzt in vielen regionen
deutschlands mit der omicron wand
konfrontiert sind es gibt also keinen
grund für entwarnung ich glaube wir
müssen nach wie vor auf die einhaltung
der des rahmens und der beschlüsse die
wir uns gesetzt haben was die frage ffp
zwei masken was die frage quarantäne
regelung die home office pflicht angeht
dem auch nachkommen wir haben eine
schutzverantwortung gerade gegenüber den
menschen die besonders gefährdet sind
das sind nach wie vor ältere menschen
das sind wohl ein arabischer gruppen
aber eben auch ganz besonders kinder und
jugendliche und ihre familien die durch
die aktuell neue infektionszahlen sehr
strapaziert und gefordert sind und
deshalb müssen bund und länder gerade
diese gruppe die familien und kinder im
blick behalten im hinblick auf die pcr
tests geht es jetzt darum
kapazitäten nach zu bekommen und bis
dahin gibt es diese priorisierung
von bestimmten gruppen hierzu gehören
die in gesundheitseinrichtungen und in
einrichtungen der eingliederungshilfe in
einrichtung der pflege und ich denke im
nächsten schritt auch die in kitas und
schulen das findet jetzt statt und das
hat volle aufmerksamkeit und
braucht auch eine gute kommunikation all
dieser maßnahmen nach außen in dieser
woche befassen wir uns im deutschen
bundestag mit der thematik impfpflicht
die wichtige orientierungs debatte ist
in dieser woche angesetzt hier werden
durch gruppen initiativen
sehr zeitnah für februar und märz
gesetzentwürfe vorbereitet auch
mitglieder meiner fraktion arbeiten an
eckpunkten für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht
mit und wir werden in der aussprache die
ja öffentlich geführt ist auch noch mal
sehr darum werben und deutlich machen
wie wichtig diese debatte im deutschen
bundestag über die einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht ist wir wissen
dass es da auch viele bedenken gibt in
der öffentlichkeit die diskutiert werden
deshalb ist glaube ich diese intensive
debatte im bundestag so wichtig und
notwendig und ich bin froh dass hier in
dieser woche stattfindet ich gehe auch
davon aus dass wir im weiteren prozess
im ersten quartal eine
gesetzentwurf oder mehrere
gesetzentwürfe zur abstimmung im
deutschen bundestag vorlegen
angesichts des gesundheitsschutzes auch
der unsicherheiten wie die weitere
entwicklung der pandemie ist des
besonderen schutzes wohlhabender gruppen
und kindern und jugendlichen spreche ich
mich auch für eine impfpflicht aus
und ich bin gespannt auf die debatte
morgen ich glaube sie wird sehr intensiv
und ist wichtig öffentlich geführt zu
werden
britta haßelmann die fraktionschefin der
bündnisgrünen sie hat noch mal begründet
das ist doch sehr gut ist dass zunächst
eine orientierungs debatte stattfindet
aber auch sie weiß natürlich dass ein
entwurf der ampel regierung keine
mehrheit gefunden hätte deswegen hat der
kanzler ja auch diesen weg gewählt den
ball hier ins parlament zu spielen ja
und die fraktionen treten hier heute
teilweise hybrid teilweise aber auch nur
digital zusammen sie sich jedenfalls
anwesend ist auch amira mohammed ali sie
ist die reine der beiden
fraktionsvorsitzenden der linksfraktion
und auch sie hat zu anfang hier das
thema des gestrigen tages bemüht nämlich
die kapriolen die zum beispiel
entstanden sind durch die frage das
gelesene plötzlich nicht mehr sechs
monate sondern nur noch drei monaten als
nicht mehr geimpft gelten das hat viele
in diesem land irritiert auch die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
wie es erleben leider dass hier immer
noch einige fragezeichen bestehen es ist
natürlich gut dass die impfkampagne
jetzt noch intensiver in angriff
genommen werden soll schlecht ist dass
das sehr spät geschieht wie als linke
haben das bereits im sommer klar
gefordert
außerdem haben wir bereits anfang
dezember ausdrücklich gefordert dass die
kapazitäten pte pcr tests schnell
ausgeweitet werden hier hat die
bundesregierung
weiterhin auf den markt gesetzt und die
auswirkungen die sehen wir leider jetzt
die kapazitäten die reichen hinten und
vorne nicht aus und die
testmöglichkeiten für menschen die sich
jetzt keine teuren bezahlt es leisten
können die fallen praktisch weg und wenn
jetzt fast zahnlose später eine erhöhung
des kapazitäten angekündigt wird ohne zu
sagen wie das passieren soll dann ist
das leider wenig
vertrauenserweckend wir brauchen
dringend eine staatliche test
infrastrukturkosten tests für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger und wir erleben
leider was viele andere dinge angeht
nach wie vor ein kommunikationschaos
dass viele fragen offen lässt ich möchte
nur ein beispiel sagen der umstand dass
der genesenen status jetzt plötzlich
nach drei monaten bereits beendet wird
wo wir vorher sechs monate hatten diese
entscheidung ist nicht vernünftig
begründet worden es wirkt wie willkür
und das sind alles dinge die kein
vertrauen stärken dabei ist genau das
ist was wir dringend brauchen und wenn
die pandemie uns eines gelehrt hat dann
das etwas was wir heute noch für richtig
halten vielleicht morgen doch sich als
nicht richtig herausstellt insofern wäre
es umso wichtiger dass die entscheidung
abgewogen und auch vernünftig und
transparent begründet werden so haben
die bürgerinnen und bürger an vielen
stellen das gefühl das sind willkürliche
entscheidung man kann sich auf nichts
verlassen und dass es für die bekämpfung
der pandemie wirklich verheerend und das
bringt mich auch zum thema impfpflicht
auch hier muss man doch sagen wenn wir
die pandemie bekämpfen wollen und
bewältigen wollen dann brauchen wir vor
allem solidarität und zusammenhalt aber
auch beim thema impfpflicht kommuniziert
die bundesregierung hier wie ich finde
desaströse ist ein zickzack kurs den wir
je erlebt haben noch vor der wahl hieß
es im pflicht kommt auf keinen fall nach
der wahl dieses jahr im pflicht kommt
und jetzt erleben wir ja
widersprüchliche aussagen auch von
mitgliedern der regierung was mich
insgesamt wundert ist dass die
einschätzung der bundesregierung sich
zumindest bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht verändert hat durch die
entwicklungen der omicron variante dabei
erleben wir ja dass die omikron variante
was die ansteckung angeht für geimpfte
gepustet den menschen werden als die
ansteckungsrate ist wesentlich höher als
noch bei der delta variante die verläufe
sind mild natürlich aber um das
infektionsgeschehen wirksam einzudämmen
bei der omicron variante wirkt die
impfung ja nachweisbar nicht so effektiv
und das sind doch dinge die man in die
erwägungen auch für eine impfpflicht
dringend mit einbeziehen musste der
ethikrat hat im herbst während die delta
variante variante ich sag mal
vorherrschen war hat sich für eine
impfpflicht mehrheitlich ausgesprochen
jetzt stellen sie die impfpflicht aber
in anbetracht der omicron situation
wieder infrage und das aus gutem grund
und hier muss ich sagen es geht wirklich
nicht dass der gesundheitsminister
gedanklich im jahr 2021 hängen bleibt
und die aktuelle lage dahingehend
ignoriert was die impfpflicht angeht
stellen sich ja nach wie vor viele
fragen ich meine wir sind uns glaube ich
darüber einig zumindest sieht meine
fraktion das so sehe ich das so dass es
ein dringendes ziel ist die impfquote zu
erhöhen eben natürlich weil auch die
impfung gegen schwere verlauf verläufe
auch bei der omicron variante schützt
das ist sehr sinnvoll
an ihrer mohammed ali die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
sie hat uns noch mal gesagt es stellen
sich viele fragen insofern ist es gut
dass es morgen eine orientierungs
debatte hier im parlament geben wird die
können sie hier bei uns bei phoenix wie
sie das gewohnt sind auch nachmittags
natürlich live miterleben ja die dritte
fraktion ist die fraktion der fdp
sie hat heute übrigens den
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier persönlich zu gast und um den
bundespräsidenten und sein amt wird es
gleich noch gehen wenn wir dann hier auf
die pressekonferenz verweisen können der
afg die dann max otte vorstellen wird
aber zunächst wollen wir ihnen einmal
zeigen was christian doerr gesagt hat
eben zu dem gestrigen beschlüssen aber
auch zur impfpflicht christian doerr der
fdp-fraktionsvorsitzende
die themen die uns diese woche
beschäftigen ist natürlich zuallererst
die korona lage die
der bund und die länder haben ja gestern
beschlossen dass die bestehende
maßnahmen so weit fortgeführt werden
sollen was angesichts des infektions
geschehens in deutschland natürlich
nachvollziehbar und auch richtig ist
richtig ist auch dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gestern
beschlossen hat dass bund und länder
gemeinsam an öffnungs perspektiven jetzt
arbeiten sie wissen dass sich die freien
demokraten genau dafür immer eingesetzt
haben und deswegen begrüßen wir das
ausdrücklich wir werden selbst auch
natürlich dazu vorschläge machen und
sobald mehr gesellschaftliches leben
möglich ist gilt es das dann auch
entsprechend umzusetzen denn eins ist
auch klar es muss irgendwann eben auch
ein ende einer pandemie geben und das
heißt eben auch dass dann mehr freiheit
mehr öffnung möglich sein wird
sukzessive selbstverständlich im rahmen
dessen was verantwortbar ist aber
gleichzeitig sollte man sich jetzt auf
den weg machen deswegen ist diese
entscheidung richtig was wir auch
begrüßen ist dass gestern in dem
beschluss eindeutig gefasst worden ist
dass es auch um eine bessere
kommunikation geht an dieser stelle das
wissen sie haben wir auch kritisiert
dass bei der änderung am gm kämpft und
genießen status doch sehr kurzfristig
durch das rk ii insbesondere
ausgelöst veränderungen vorgenommen
worden sind die deutsche öffentlichkeit
verunsichert haben und natürlich auch
beim thema akzeptanz muss man aufpassen
dass man solche entscheidungen nicht zu
kurzfristig trifft diese entscheidung
müssen jederzeit nachvollziehbar sein
und das heißt eben auch dass man das
frühzeitig ankündigen muss das darf
nicht einen überraschungseffekt haben
und deswegen sind wir damit den minister
printen der länder und dem bundeskanzler
einig dass da in zukunft eine bessere
kommunikation an den tag gelegt werden
muss wir werden am morgigen mittwoch
nachmittag eine debatte über das thema
impfpflicht haben das ist für uns das
haben wir schon im dezember gesagt eine
medizin ethische frage die es eben von
allen seiten abzuwägen gilt bei der
impfpflicht das ist mir wichtig gibt es
nicht nur schwarz und weiß es wird
voraussichtlich am ende drei anträge
drei stossrichtungen geben einerseits
natürlich die ablehnung einer
impfpflicht aber möglicherweise auch
eine gestufte impfpflicht beispielsweise
nach altersgruppen und eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 18 jahren denen sich die
abgeordneten dann aus unterschiedlichen
fraktionen anschließen können wir führen
diese woche die bei den fragestellung
dieser art bewährte orientierungs
debatte das ist wichtig dass zunächst
einmal auch öffentlich ganz breit
diskutiert wird welche möglichkeiten
bestehen und dann werden wir das
natürlich auch innerhalb der fraktion in
den kommenden wochen weiter diskutieren
ich glaube solche orientierungs debatten
sind wichtig für den parlamentarismus
und es werden auch aus unserer fraktion
dort verschiedene stimmen zu wort kommen
verschiedene stimmen heißt eben auch mit
unterschiedlichen positionen und das ist
gut und richtig so ich will an dieser
stelle vielleicht noch mal an die
kollegen kollegen der unionsfraktion
appellieren da hatte man ja in den
letzten wochen das hat sich vielleicht
in den letzten tagen leicht gebessert
den eindruck dass eine solche
orientierungs debatte von seiten der
union nicht gewünscht ist obwohl wir
gleichzeitig natürlich auch verschiedene
stimmen zum thema impfpflicht aus der
union wahrnehmen ich hielte es für einen
fehler wenn man sich an ein solcher
orientierungs debatte nicht inhaltlich
beteiligt denn wie ich vorhin schon
sagte politische entscheidungsprozesse
müssen transparent sein und sie müssen
transparent gemacht werden und wir
freuen uns sehr wenn die union auch zu
dieser erkenntnis am morgigen tag kommen
würde weiteres thema was uns in dieser
sitzungswoche beschäftigt ist der
nachtragshaushalt für das jahr 2021
also ein finanz und haushaltspolitisches
thema der bundestag wird ja den
nachtragshaushalt in dieser woche
beschließen um somit wichtige
zukunftsinvestitionen zu ermöglichen die
pandemie bedingt bisher nicht umgesetzt
werden konnten und wir freuen uns sehr
dass der bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner gelungen ist in diesem
zusammenhang auch die ursprünglich
geplante nettokreditaufnahme des
vergangenen jahres noch einmal um rund
25 milliarden euro zu reduzieren
das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger punkt
zum thema solidität der öffentlichen
finanzen in den letzten tagen gab es
auch eine debatte um die bereits im
koalitionsvertrag
angelehnte bereits skizzierte
abschaffung geplante abschaffung der eeg
umlage
die fdp fraktion wird sich für diesen
ersten entlastungsschritt natürlich
einsetzen das war eines unserer
herzensanliegen auch während der
koalitionsverhandlungen wir werden mit
den ampel partnern beraten dass das
früher gelingt als zum ersten erst 2023
mein ziel bleibt hier eine abschöpfung
bis zum herbst das müssen wir genau
schauen wie man das umsetzen kann das
werden wir innerhalb der ampel koalition
selbstverständlich beraten aber ich
halte das vor dem hintergrund der
installation in deutschland für ein
wichtiges signal an die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher
weiterer punkt der uns beschäftigen wird
ist natürlich die ukraine krise die lage
an der ukrainisch-russischen grenze ist
weiter besorgniserregend
und für uns ist eins klar die
ukrainische unabhängigkeit und die
territoriale integrität des landes sind
nicht verhandelbar natürlich setzen wir
hier weiter auf die diplomatischen wege
um aus dieser krise herauszukommen und
rufen russland dazu auf an den
verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren
herrn putin muss klar sein dass wir als
europäische union gemeinsam mit unseren
amerikanischen partnern im falle einer
militärischen eskalation entschieden und
hart gegen russland vorgehen werden
schwerwiegende wirtschaftliche und
politische folgen für russland hätte das
eben zur folge der die europäische union
ist der größte binnenmarkt der welt der
größte zusammenhängende wirtschaftsraum
auf der einen seite auf der anderen
seite ist russland als volkswirtschaft
gerade einmal doppelt so groß wie die
der schweiz das zeigt auch dass wir hier
auch ein wirtschaftliches gewicht in die
waagschale werfen können und es gibt ja
optionen ich eine beispielsweise an eine
forderung der fdp auch aus
oppositionszeiten
stichwort magnitski act russische
oligarchen können dann eben nicht mehr
um es mal salopp zu formulieren über den
kudamm zum shoppen gehen sondern da sind
aktionen durchaus möglich aber wir
müssen eben auch zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht alle optionen öffentlich
diskutieren herr putin tut das ja
schließlich auch nicht aber es muss klar
sein dass europa und deutschland hier
bereit ist zu handeln
ja und von der außenpolitik wollen wir
noch mal eben die innenpolitik springen
christian doerr gleich die ehre hier das
deutsche staatsoberhaupt zu empfangen
frank walter steinmeier hat sich heute
angesagt zu gast bei der fdp fraktion
die in größten teilen hier physisch
anwesend sein wird logisch wer will sich
das schon entgehen lassen die fdp hat
vor fünf jahren ebenfalls frank walter
steinmeier sehr früh mitgetragen und
auch dieses mal ist es so gewesen dass
christian lindner schon sehr früh
entschieden hat die liberalen stehen an
der seite des sozialdemokraten des
amtierenden präsidenten und werden ihn
wieder wählen das war ja bei den grünen
dann schon ein prozess der etwas länger
gedauert hat ja und schlagzeilen macht
heute natürlich die afd weil sie einen
kandidaten aufbieten wird der gar nicht
bei ihnen in der partei ist sondern
cdu-mitglied nominiert ist der
vorsitzende der werte union die werte
union ist eine vereinigung von circa
4000 mitgliedern dabei vor allen dingen
cdu-mitglieder es ist aber keine
offizielle vereinigung der cdu muss man
klar sagen und max otte leitet diese
vereinigung seit einem knappen jahr und
hat sich jetzt dazu entschlossen das
angebot der afg wahrzunehmen das hat er
schon den agenturen gesagt wir warten
jetzt in diesen minuten auf ihn hier
dann wird das offiziell als
pressekonferenz wird der kandidat noch
mal vorgestellt werden der 57 jährige
ökonom ist ja sehr weit rechts in der
cdu das kann man nicht anders sagen und
löst mit diesem schritt eine wilde
empörung innerhalb der christdemokraten
aus und er selbst sein vorgänger der
gründer der werte union herr mitch hat
gesagt so geht es nicht er hat ihn
aufgerufen dass sein zu lassen und jetzt
schalten wir über zur afd und zur
nominierung von herrn otte frankfurt
sagen genau
heute viel los
so verehrte
pressevertreter
herzlich begrüßen
das mikro 1
er macht das an
jetzt ist ein
anfang es
ist ein
genau
[Applaus]
geht jetzt am anfang gut okay wir fangen
wir an sehr geehrte pressevertreter
herzlich willkommen heute zu unserem
pressestatement vor der fraktionssitzung
aus gegebenen anlass haben wir heute
professor max otte hier den wir gestern
als bundesvorstand aber auch mit der
einwilligung und auch großen bestätigung
aller landesvorsitzende afd
zur unserem
bundespräsidentschaftskandidaten
ernannten professor heute
sie wissen alle hat professor otte ist
ein honoriger politiker chef der werte
union und seite ein guter tag für die
demokratie in deutschland
denn wir haben eine alternative zu den
beiden linken kandidaten um das amt des
bundespräsidenten wir geben damit allen
wahldelegierten die möglichkeit ein mann
aus der mitte auch an diesem 13 februar
zu wählen und deswegen freue ich mich
und möchte mich recht herzlich bedanken
professor max otte das ja auch zur
verfügung steht und für uns dort als
bundespräsidentschaftskandidat auch ein
steht vielen dank
ja auch von meiner seite vielen
herzlichen dank herr professor otte
demokratie lebt von beteiligung
und wir sind es nicht nur unseren
wählern schuldig eine wahlalternative
zudem spd bundespräsidenten zu stellen
und dass die cdu keinen eigenen
kandidaten aufgestellt hat
zeigt
dass sie noch nicht in ihrer
oppositionsrolle hinein gefunden hat und
wir sorgen dafür durch einen
wertkonservativen liberalen kandidaten
wie professor orte dass dem parlament
und der bundeswahl versammlung eine
alternative geboten wird und dass
ausgerechnet die cdu dafür doch
tatsächlich darüber nachdenkt professor
orte als chef der werte union aus der
partei zu werfen
entbehrt nicht einer gewissen komik mit
herrn otte haben wir einen
ehrwürdigen
bundespräsidentenkandidat er hat
internationale erfahrung
der internationale kontakte ist ein
erfolgreicher fondsmanager
und ist zugleich bodenständig und
heimatverbunden
was könnten wir uns mehr von einem
bundespräsidenten für unser land
wünschen herr otte sie haben das wort
vielen dank
es ist ja schon in der presse verlautet
worden
lieber herr kopp aller liebe frau weigel
dass das dass ich das als große ehre am
see als etwas was über den parteien
steht es ist geht um das amt es geht um
die würde des amtes
bedanke mich bei meiner frau bei meiner
familie dass sie das mittragen denn es
wird natürlich in den nächsten wochen
einiges auf mich ein stürmen also ganz
herzlichen dank dass sie das mittragen
ich sehe dieses amt als eine möglichkeit
und die kandidatur zeichen zu setzen es
sind mir wichtig die sozialen themen da
habe ich durchaus überschneidungen
punkte zum anderen gegenkandidaten und
ich habe die letzten jahre immer darauf
hingewiesen dass für eine soziale
verarmung haben in deutschland einen
abstieg der mittelschicht dass wir das
tun müssen dass die vermögens- schere zu
weit auseinander geht ich sehe das amt
als eine möglichkeit darauf hinzuweisen
oder die kandidatur
dass wir über unsere freiheitsrechte
nachdenken müssen ich bin
in diesem hause noch gelesen wenn ich
aus dem haus heraus gehe bin ich das
nicht also von daher glaube ich dass da
wirklich
arbeit notwendig ist meine werdegang
können sie nachlesen da brauche ich
heute nicht viel zu sagen möchte nur
soviel sagen mein vater ist teilte die
eu mitglied gewesen in der straße in der
ich gewohnt habe gab es den
spd-bürgermeister mein vater als
cdu-spitzenkandidaten und auch ja den
spitzenkandidaten der dkp und alle drei
haben
heftig diskutiert und wenn sie mit dem
diskutieren fertig waren haben sie skat
gespielt und so wünsche ich mir in
gewisser weise dass politik wieder
stattfindet natürlich ist es im
tagesgeschäft etwas härter aber wir
müssen zur menschlichkeit zurückfinden
zur menschlichkeit in die halle wir
müssen an die wirklichen probleme des
landes gehen und da ist die rolle und
das amt des bundespräsidenten eine rolle
zu versöhnen den dialog zu suchen
zu einem nicht zu spalten und auch zu
mahnen wo es notwendig ist so sehe ich
das amt und das amt steht über den
parteien und ich kann noch mal sagen das
ist als große ehre an sie auch wenn es
natürlich von der verteilung so ist wie
es ist vielen dank
[Musik]
warum stellen den eigenen kandidaten auf
der camper keine chance hat und warum
also das ist erst einmal in
demokratischer prozess dass sie von
vornherein schon sagen dass ein kandidat
keine chance hat das
muss eigentlich ihrem
demokratieverständnis wirklich zweifel
zweifel geben sie wissen es gibt ist
eine geheime wahl die dort stattfindet
wir wollten frau hat es richtigerweise
gesagt eine alternative aufstellen auch
eine wahlalternative und ich plädiere
auch an die öffentlich-rechtlichen
fernsehanstalten ähnlich wie es beim
bundeskanzler war doch ein fernseh
dialog zu führen oder 1 tl so ist es ja
mal seinerzeit dann können auch die
kandidaten sich dort im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk besser vorstellen
und ich denke es die gelegenheit auch
für die wahldelegierten einen eindruck
zu gewinnen welche positionen der
kandidat steht und dann denke ich fällt
auch die wahlentscheidung für manche die
dann an diesen 13 februar vor ort sind
leichter
ich gebe keine prognosen ab mitbestimmen
ich damit rechnen wir gehen sehr
optimistisch in diese wahlveranstaltung
hinein
um die jetzt beispielsweise einen
parteiaustritt fordern und liegt er ihn
vielleicht von selbst da wollen sie cdu
mitglied bleiben also bei mir hat noch
niemand angerufen und die frage mit mir
diskutiert wenn das so wäre würde ich
sicherlich mit demjenigen oder
derjenigen diskutieren aber ich sehe
keinen grund auf solche sachen in den
medien einzugehen das amt steht über den
parteien so sehe ich ist die kandidatur
steht über den parteien
von daher sehe ich da kein anlass
das schlicht anders oder also haben sie
als parteimitglied trotzdem das recht
man vorgeschlagen wird für das höchste
staatsamt was über den parteien steht
ist das in meinen augen keine
zusammenarbeit ist eine individuelle
entscheidung ob ich diese diesen
vorschlag annehmen oder nicht und ich
kann nur sagen dass ich dieses amt als
überparteilich ansehe und so gott will
auch überparteilich ausüben würde
identifizieren sie sich damit den
positionen der afg sie sind ja von ihr
doch schon der kandidat also müssen sie
auch eine verbindung zu dieser partei
ich will ihnen mal ein konkretes
beispiel geben zum thema cupid corona da
sagte mir jemand das seien doch afd
position nein das sind positionen
gewesen die ich schon deutlich vorher
vertreten habe bevor die afd dort ihre
richtung gefunden hat also von daher
sind es meine position sie können meine
positionen in meinen büchern nachlesen
das letzte feld systemcrash wo ich etwas
über den abstieg der mittelschicht
schreibe
das könnten sie als linksliberal ansehen
was da drin steht in dem buch steht
eigentlich sehr viel drin ist in 600
seiten also ich habe meine position
eigentlich nicht geändert eine position
ist mir wichtig die macht der
technologiekonzerne das war ein großes
thema
vor fünf sechs sieben jahren bei den
sozialdemokraten ich habe an einem
sammelband mit geschrieben mit
schirrmacher döpfner gabriel martin
schulz juli zeh sascha lobo und so
weiter bei suhrkamp können sie da noch
finden der sammelband ist sechs jahre
alt die macht der technologiekonzerne
ist mittlerweile kein so großes thema
mehr bei den sozialdemokraten bei mir
schon bei mir schon weil ich glaube dass
diese konzerne
ungebührlichen einfluss auf unsere
lebensrealität ausüben
das eigentlich auch mit der gesamtpartei
tun haben sie da bedenken jetzt mit der
für die fdp anzutreten was die
verfassung zu sein
ich habe mich sehr intensiv und lange
mit einem ehemaligen präsidenten des
verfassungsschutzes ausgetauscht und
ich beobachte mit sorge dass der
verfassungsschutz zu einem regierenden
schutz wird und das ist nicht seine
aufgabe
nochmal sie haben das mit ihrer familie
besprochen sie haben auch gesagt das amt
biete die chance zu heilen zu versuchen
zu ermahnen hat ihre familie sie dann
auch mal gefragt warum sie dann
ausgerechnet mit einer provokation
beginnen weil genauso nehmen es ja alle
anderen parteien war ich sehe es nicht
als provokation an es ist mir ernst ich
habe ihn von meiner kindheit erzählt ich
bin einer dialog kultur aufgewachsen ich
sehe es als möglichkeit wenn sich die
hysterie gelegt hat gräben zuzuschütten
gräben zu begradigen den dialog zu
stärken
bitte haben sie den eindruck dass gerade
verwöhnt war viel tun ich glaube ja wenn
man auf dauer sich überlegt das ist ein
normaler demokratischer vorgang ist dass
der dialog wieder in gang kommt hoffe
ich dass es dazu beiträgt ja
trend so weiter also max otte ich bin
mir nicht ganz sicher ob es ein normaler
demokratischer vorgang ist dass eine
partei einen kandidaten einer anderen
partei vorschlägt max otte hat gesagt er
möchte einen statt spalten ich kann ich
in den nicht reinschauen ich weiß nicht
ob er das wirklich glaubt die afg spitze
jedenfalls glaubt etwas anderes sie
glaubt dass sie spalten kann nämlich
dass cdu csu lager sie erwartet stimmen
für den sehr konservativen max otte auch
aus reihen der cdu/csu und das ist ja
auch kein geheimnis natürlich gab es in
der union auch unzufriedene stimmen dass
man frank walter steinmeier erneut
unterstützen würden keinen eigenen
kandidaten aufstellt aber dennoch ich
hatte vorhin schon gesagt selbst der
gründer der wertung union herr mick hat
sich massiv distanziert hat gesagt so
geht das nicht hat max otte aufgefordert
dieses sein zu lassen denn damit
überschreitet er eine grenze die ihn
wahrscheinlich auch seinen partei- titel
kosten könnte er wird die cdu
mitgliedschaft nicht selber abgeben das
haben wir schon gelernt sondern es muss
dann einen ausschuss verfahren gegen ihn
eingeleitet werden und die cdu spitze
ist gewillt dies zu tun wie das paul
team jagt der immer noch amtierende
generalsekretär und mario czaja der
dieses amt ab dem 31 januar die jure
erst ausführen kann wie diese beiden
generalsekretäre heute vor der presse
betont haben
wer mit der afg kooperiert oder
zusammenarbeitet hat in der cdu nichts
zu suchen der kann in der cdu nicht
verbleiben wir haben daher einen dr otto
heute aufgefordert bis 17 uhr 30 zu
erklären ob er die nominierung des afg
bundesvorstandes annimmt und wir haben
zugleich zu einer sitzung des
amtierenden bundesvorstandes heute um 18
uhr eingeladen um über das weitere
verfahren in der sache und im umgang mit
herrn dr otto zu sprechen und dann zu
beschließen der doktor max otte mitglied
der christlich demokratischen union
wurde am gestrigen montag bundesvorstand
der afd für das amt des
bundespräsidenten nominiert dieser
nominierung hat der doktor otte nicht
widersprochen laut eigener aussage
erwägt er vielmehr die annahme der
nominierung durch die afd
wer dies als christdemokrat überhaupt
erwägt von der afg für das amt des
bundespräsidenten nominiert zu werden
der verletzt die werte der cdu und hat
in unserer partei nichts verloren
damit verstößt der doktor otte gegen
zahlreiche beschlüsse der eigenen partei
und verletzt auch das will ich hier ganz
ausdrücklich sagen die loyalität und
solidarität
verpflichtung als mitglied gegenüber der
cdu wenn nicht unverzüglich und ohne
jedes zögern ausschließlich von
wahlfrauen und wahlmännern der fdp für
das höchste amt in unserem staate wählen
zu lassen verletzt das wertefundament
der cdu in einem so erheblichen maße
dass er keinen platz in der cdu mehr
haben kann wir fordern auch ganz
ausdrücklich an dr otto auf die cdu zu
verlassen märz hat das würde ja noch mal
verschärft zwischen den jahren und
gesagt es müsse wer auch mal mit der afg
zusammenarbeite einen parteiausschluss
geben bringt sie das auch ein bisschen
in die situation ist jetzt durchaus
mehrere solche fälle geben könnte und
sie jedes mal zu diesem mittel greifen
wir haben uns heute mit dieser frage
beschäftigt es handelt sich hier um die
nominierung für das amt des
bundespräsidenten deswegen ist das
gremium was sich damit beschäftigt dann
heute abend der bundesvorstand der cdu
das tun wir aber wie gesagt ausdrücklich
in absprache mit dem zuständigen
kreisverband auch in köln cdu
landesverband nordrhein westfalen
und deswegen haben wir uns heute am
bisherigen tage mit dieser frage
beschäftigte also dieser nominierung von
den traktor otte weil es sich um das amt
des bundespräsidenten handelt was tun
sie denn wenn er bis 17.30 nicht erklärt
dass er doch nicht antreten wird bzw
wenn er das bis dahin erklärt ist dann
alles wieder in butter und ok und was
sagen sie als zweite frage zu seiner
argumentation dass das amt des
bundespräsidenten überparteilich sein
und schließlich würde ja die union oder
teile der union auch eine spd politiker
unterstützen deswegen sei das ja gar
nichts besonderes
also erstens werden wir uns heute ist es
ja nicht das erste mal dass herr dr otto
gegen
regularien der union verstoßen hat oder
mindestens sehr weiter an die grenze
geführt hat in diesem fall ist allein
schon dass darüber nachdenken und nicht
unverzüglich auszuschließen aus unserer
sicht ein verstoß gegen unsere
regularien und auch ein verstoß gegen
die loyalität gegenüber der cdu und zu
ihrer zweiten frage wir haben eine
beschlusslage zu einem kandidaten
damit ist die nominierung von einem
anderen kandidaten ein verstoß gegen die
beschlusslage und es verschärft sich
noch mal im besonderen dass man es nicht
ausschließt für die afg überhaupt
nominiert zu werden also sie würden dann
in der vorstandssitzung heute abend ein
ausschlussverfahren gegen herrn otte
beschließen wir werden heute über die
weiteren schritte im bundesvorstand
heute abend beraten ausschlussverfahren
ist da ganz klar auch mit beinhaltet
dann lassen sie mich eine bemerkung noch
dazu machen der blank weil sie jetzt
gefragt haben nach einiger juristischer
raffinesse ich will das mal ganz
menschlich und auch persönlich
beantworten
wir sind nicht bereit für irgendwelche
spielchen sondern solche und das ist
nicht das erste mal führt der partei der
cdu schaden zu diese vorgehensweise und
nach allem eindruck den man gewinnen
kann ist das auch bewusst so geplant
dass es sich das erste mal dass herr
otte gegen regularien verstößt 2018 als
ausrichter des hambacher festes
schulterschluss mit der afg dann
sein wirken in der desi delius stiftung
warum erst jetzt warum reagieren sie
erst jetzt oder kündigen sie erst jetzt
eine solche härte im umgang mit ihm an
ich habe das gerade schon gesagt es gibt
ja eine klare regelung wer für etwas
zuständig ist ob zum beispiel die
kreisverbände die landesverbände das
können sie alles im statut nachlesen es
handelt sich hier um die nominierung für
das amt des bundespräsidenten deswegen
beschäftigt sich auch der bundesvorstand
mit dieser frage und es geht hier um
eine nominierung eine offizielle
nominierung einer partei nämlich der afd
und deswegen sie kennen auch die
beschlüsse des hamburger parteitages von
2018 und jetzt diese nominierung und
deswegen ist es hier rechtlich jetzt
auch geboten sich in dieser weise damit
zu beschäftigen und hertha hat es gerade
gesagt wir haben ihn jetzt aufgefordert
die seine erklärung dazu abzugeben und
werden dann im lichte der ereignisse des
gestrigen heutigen tages heute mit dem
bundesvorstand über die maßnahmen
beraten
ja und ich hoffe im adenauer haus hat
man für nichts gesehen denn dann konnte
man hören eben das max otto seine
meinung nicht ändert er sieht das als
völlig normal an und als große ehre dass
die afd ihn zum
bundespräsidentenkandidaten hier
befördert hat er ist ja immer noch
vorsitzender der werte union immer noch
mitglied der cdu und hans georg maas
nein anderes mitglied was häufig
schlagzeilen machte hat gesagt so geht
das nicht auf den tisch gehauen und ist
aus der werte union aus protest
ausgetreten für eine andere partei zu
kandidieren das geht zu weit selbst
hans-georg maßen wir haben natürlich
reaktion von den fraktionschefs die wir
ihnen eben schon mal gezeigt haben wir
wollen anfang mit britta haßelmann
ich glaube dass diese nominierung
deutlich zeigt dass die frage von werten
und haltung und einer klaren
positionierung im hinblick auf unsere
lebendige demokratie
bei der werte union große fehlanzeige
ist für mich ist das nichts neues viele
von uns wussten das schon sehr lange und
es wird sehr wichtig sein dass die
cdu/csu und auch der neue
parteivorsitzende friedrich merz sich
hier klar und eindeutig positionieren es
gibt die möglichkeit jeder fraktion von
mit der bundesversammlung da jetzt
vorschlags rechte zu machen es ist keine
frage dass er heute nicht unsere
unterstützung hat inwiefern er als
cdu-mitglied werte union inwiefern das
dazu herausforderungen für überlasse ich
den anderen kollegen insofern werte ich
das nicht weiter aber selbstverständlich
hat jemand wie heute niemals zu keinem
zeitpunkt die unterstützung der freien
demokraten auch in seinen äußerungen
widerspricht er all dem für auch an
werten für das für die die fdp steht das
ist denke ich eine eine frage die vor
allem die kolleginnen und kollegen von
der union beantworten müssen ich habe
jetzt gehört dass der herr
ausgeschlossen werden soll aus der cdu
es ist eine frage die sich vor allem die
die die cdu/csu stellen muss ob sie da
ich sage meinen kritischen blick darauf
haben sollten
welche welche menschen werden ihren
reihen unterwegs sind wenn es zum
wiederholten male geschieht dass da
leute von von der union zur fdp wechseln
da muss man doch ständig ein auge darauf
haben aber das ist tatsächlich eine ein
vorrang der vor allem die cdu/csu zurück
denken bewegen sollte
die linke hat ja auch einen eigenen
kandidaten aufgestellt mit gerhard
trabert aber da gab es diese
verwicklungen nicht gerhard trabert
selber hat ja gesagt er tritt an und
weiß von vornherein dass er natürlich
keine mehrheit bekommen wird krupp hat
das grazer dargestellt als wenn max otte
wirklich gewinnen könnte in der
bundesversammlung was natürlich völlig
illusorisch ist ja und was ist jetzt mit
der cdu fraktion die cdu csu fraktion
bietet hier heute ein novum
der fraktionschef ist nicht physisch
anwesend sondern hat vor seiner sitzung
hier digital mitgeteilt was jetzt in dem
einen oder anderen so denkt
häufig in den fraktionssitzungen dieser
woche haben wir wieder einen ganzen
bunten straße und themen lager und
erfreuliche themen das ist nämlich der
russland ukraine konflikt wir uns sehr
beschäftigt wir betrachten die situation
als sehr sehr gefährlich wir als unions
fraktion wissen wo wir da stehen für uns
ist die souveränität der ukraine nicht
verhandelbar die ukraine hat das recht
auf selbstverteidigung wobei wir auch
unterstützen
sollten und wir brauchen eine lösung in
europäischen im transatlantischen
schulterschluss das ist wichtig und
dafür ist es auch wichtig dass alle
sanktionsmöglichkeiten auf dem tisch
bleiben das heißt dass wir nichts
ausschließen wir müssen handlungsfähig
seien es geht bei der sache um sehr sehr
viel es ist eine äußerst kritische
situation ich würde mich freuen wenn die
bundesregierung an dieser stelle mehr
führung zeigen würde welt insbesondere
der bundeskanzler oder schossen
sichtbarer wäre wir sehen es nicht dass
es so ist wie es bei angela merkel
gewesen ist dass deutschland ein
positives szenario führungsfunktion
übernommen hat und das ist schädlich und
das kritisieren wir auch ausdrücken der
zweite punkte auch ein sehr wenig
erfreuliches thema ist das thema corona
werden gestern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das
wesentliche ergebnis ministerpräsidenten
zusammen mit der bundesregierung war das
pcr-test rationiert werden sollen wir
sind hier weil auch das aller aller
schnellstens die organisatorischen
voraussetzungen geschaffen werden müssen
dass pcr test also weiterhin breit
verfügbar sind nun ist also auch ein
ganz ganz wichtiges instrument ist
gerade jetzt bei höheren instanzen und
ehrlich gesagt ich kann das auch nicht
verstehen dass er jetzt auch vorgänger
gebucht wird es ist so dieser
gesundheitsminister ist seit knapp zwei
monaten im amt er warnte allabendlich in
diversen sendungen davor dass die uni
kommt wer da auf uns zurollt ich erwarte
von ihm auch dass er da die
entsprechenden vorkehrungen trifft dass
er das zusammen mit der bundesregierung
macht wir werden eine orientierungs
debatte haben zum thema impfpflicht wir
sind immer noch der meinung dass es
besser gewesen wäre wenn die
bundesregierung bei so einer wichtigen
frage eine meinung gehabt hätte wir
haben gerade die beantwortung unserer
kleinen anfrage bekommen nach einer
gewissen verzögerung so zieht sich die
bundesregierung im wesentlichen darauf
zurück dass hier das parlament ist was
da vorschläge gemacht das ist nicht
richtig findet einer so entscheidenden
frage der bundesregierung nicht in der
lage ist eine einheitliche position
einzunehmen dann zeigt es dass sich
handlungsfähig ist also für mich ist das
das verhalten einer minderheitsregierung
was darauf hofft dass in skandinavischen
sinne die cdu/csu als stütz fraktion zur
verfügung steht das wären wir nicht sein
wir werden aber auch sehr konsequent an
eigenen lösungsmöglichkeiten arbeiten
die beantwortung der kleinen anfrage
bekommen wir sind eine fraktionsinternen
prozessen 1 schält sich hier schon
heraus es ist ganz ganz wichtig
zumindestens mittel und langfristig auch
eine lösung mit einem ins register
hinzubekommen ins register ist unseres
erachtens notwendig um auch weitere
schritte vornehmen zu können möchte an
dieser stelle nochmals betonen es geht
jetzt bei dem thema pflicht nicht um die
aktuelle welle aber wenn wir die
experten ernst und das tun wir ist es so
dass wir auf dem herbst vorbereitet
sagen müssen und dann müssen wir eine
lösung haben wie wir umgehen wenn die
quoten nicht hoch genug sind und da
werden wir konstruktiv daran mitarbeiten
wir haben den holocaust
gedenktag und es ist notwendiger denn je
dass wir diesen gedenktag machen das
land ist gekennzeichnet von einer
zunehmenden radikalisierung
wir hatten in den letzten jahren
erschreckende vorfälle im bereich
rechtsextremismus und im bereich
antisemitismus und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass der deutsche bundestag
da an diesen tagen auch flagge zeigt es
ist wichtig dass die
bundestagspräsidentin hochkarätige gäste
eingeladen hat um zu zeigen wie wichtig
ist den höchsten verfassungsorgan ist
dass wir nicht nur bedenken sondern dass
wir aus dem denken auch impulse
mitnehmen für unser aktives politisches
handeln
ralph brinkhaus der fraktionschef der
cdu/csu heute digital warum ist das so
er wollte mit dem kollegen mathias
middelberg gemeinsam auftreten aus
zeitgründen können wir ihn seine
stellungnahme nicht zeigen und herr
mittelberg ist neu in seinem wahlkreis
gebunden deswegen hat die cdu/csu sich
entschieden heute hier digital stellung
zu nehmen offensichtlich zu der
personalie max otte ist ja nicht gefragt
worden waren ja auch keine journalisten
da obwohl es hinterher glaube ich der
fragerunde gab aber wir haben ja die
töne der cdu csu gehört max otte
kandidiert also als kandidat für die afg
und die union behält sich vor
entsprechende schritte einzuleiten das
ist das geraschel am heutigen tage
schauen wir noch mal auf die woche was
ja auch gerade ralph brinkhaus schon
getan hat auf die wirklich wichtigen
politischen themen da geht es nämlich am
morgen dann in der orientierung debatte
um die frage impfpflicht oder nicht das
lohnt sich sicherlich auch für die
eigene argumentation da mal rein zu
schalten bei phoenix kurz nach drei
morgen hier bei uns auf dem programm
vorher schon um 13 uhr robert habeck der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
in der befragung bei den kollegen hier
im parlament und robert habeck
am freitag um viertel vor neun bei
phoenix zu sehen wird am freitag eine
regierungserklärung zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
abgeben ja und am donnerstag auch ganz
wichtig die holocaust gedenkstunde im
deutschen bundestag und im laufe des
tages dann der wichtige
nachtragshaushalt der verabschiedet
werden soll sie sehen meine damen und
herren es gibt viele viele themen max
otte ist da wohl eher eine
randerscheinung aber eine ganz
brandaktuelle am heutigen tage und damit
zurück in unser studio nach bonn zu
claudia
vielen dank
für diese muntere